what is money
and what is the role of money in the
history of human civilization money is a
medium of exchange the thing that
defines money is that it is a good that
you don't buy for its own sake because
you want to consume it itself or because
you want to
employ it in the production of other
goods which is what capital goods are so
we have consumption goods we have
capital goods money is distinct from
those two because it is a good that is
acquired purely to be exchanged later on
for other goods so
it's not something that you acquire for
its own sake you acquire it so that you
can then later on exchange it and that's
a market good
that's a market good like all other
goods you know it's uh you you acquire
food because you eat it you acquire a
car to move you around you acquire money
so that you can exchange it for other
goods
and that's something that
many people have a hard time grasping of
the concept of money as a market good
but it is a market because just like all
others
and the importance of it is that it
allows us to trade it allows us to
develop um
to develop the division of labor which
would not be possible at any kind of
sophisticated level without money so
if um you know if we live in a small
society of 10 people then think about
all the things that we can make all the
things that we can produce
if we're
only 10 people isolated from the world
there's only very few things that we can
make and therefore
we can exchange those things directly
with one another but as you know if we
get
in contact with other
societies that have more people
then the opportunities for
specialization increase you know if
there's 10 people the only thing that
you can make is
the very basics you need for your
survival but if you're part of an
economy of 10 million people there's
much more room for specialization you
can make a car you can make a house
that's very more sophisticated and that
relies on the division of labor that
relies on you
specializing in doing one tiny little
thing
which is not what you consume you know
you can and you trade that thing for all
the things that you consume so
as the economy becomes more
sophisticated and involves more people
and currently we're all part of a of an
economy of almost eight billion people
um each one of us produces one tiny
little thing and they exchange that
thing
for all the things that they want and so
because we specialize we become more
productive in doing the thing that we're
good at so you know there's people out
there who are engineers who are
designing windshields in cars it's a
very specialized thing they sell
windshield design to mercedes-benz and
then from that
you know that windshield design is added
onto millions of cars around the world
and from that they're able to get enough
money to meet all of their needs so the
division of labor is enhanced enormously
with money because without money it's
very difficult to be able to exchange
a large number of goods it's very
difficult to have a sophisticated
economy with a large degree of
specialization because
um it's very difficult to find people
who want the thing that you have and
have the thing that you want we call
this the coincidence of once
and that's really the problem that money
solves so you make apples and i make
oranges
i'd like to have some of your apples but
you don't want my oranges that's we have
a problem of coincidence of one so what
do i do you want bananas i need to find
somebody who has bananas give them my
oranges take their bananas give you
their bananas and then i take the apples
in that case bananas are a medium of
exchange
so it's natural that a medium exchange
will evolve and will emerge in an
economy as an economy becomes more
sophisticated as we move beyond
10 people and 10 goods it's inevitable
that we're going to come to a situation
where we have the problem of coincidence
of wants
and the way to solve that is to use a
medium of exchange and it can be
anything it can be a banana it can be
food stuff it can be any kind of good
as long as i acquire the good with the
purpose of it passing it on to you not
for the purpose of me consuming it or
using it then that's a medium of
exchange so when we look at the entirety
of human society of millions of billions
of people you think of them just a bunch
of individuals running around
i love the
the term coincidence of wants so each
one of them it's like a stochastic
system
they have desires it's like random
collection of desires some somehow
rooted in our evolutionary history but
mostly random in terms of preference of
banana or apple that kind of thing
and then they also have the capacity
for competence and excellence in
particular kind of labor it's like uh
specialization they're able to be like
incredible at a particular set of tasks
so there's a bunch of ants running
around
with consciousness and intelligence and
they have desires and they have
capabilities and then um there's a
coincidence
of both the the wants they have and the
capabilities they have and you wanted to
create a system that kind of um
exchanges those things so when you
imagine
like uh what is a good what is markets
when you imagine a market is like a
hierarchical
system like what do you imagine what is
a market
a market is just the name for the
naturally emerging phenomena of people
voluntarily exchanging things it's at
any scale
at any scale yeah um individual it could
be a market of two people on an island
on their own it could be eight billion
people across the planet um naturally
emerging
yes this is the thing i think that is
very hard for many
people who don't have a good
understanding of economics to grasp that
capitalism and markets are not
something that you need a
central planner or a government officer
to make happen
capitalism is just what happens when
people are left to their own devices
it's just our cognitive capacity allows
us to
develop tools that we can use for
production and
that's what we do that's what humans
have been doing since they started
you know making spears to hunt that's
the first capital good probably so we're
constantly accumulating capital we're
constantly trading with one another we
find an opportunity you know you've got
a lot of oranges i've got a lot of
apples
then i'll take some of yours you'll take
some of mine we're both better off this
is just a naturally emergent thing
and money is what makes it enormously
powerful money money is what allows it
to scale really money is what allows it
to go beyond
uh small
societies into just something that is
global
because with money
um again as i was saying earlier you
know all you need to do is specialize in
doing one thing the things you do best
and then you exchange that for money and
you don't have to worry about whether
the other people involved in this
want what you have and have what you
want you just sell it for money to
whoever wants it and you buy whatever
you want from whoever has it and that's
um an enormous reduction in the mental
burden of how a market economy functions
so the first thing that i would say
about money is that it allows for the
division of labor and it allows for the
market system to grow and the second
thing is that money is a mechanism for
storing value into the future
so
again as humans we develop the capacity
to think
for the future we you know we we make a
spears so that we can hunt and then we
see that it works and then we take it
out of the animal that we hunted it with
and we keep it for the next day's hunt
and then we start making a better spear
and we make a better fishing rod and
then we make a fishing net and we make a
fishing boat and that's our ability to
think of the future
and as we start building durable goods
we start thinking more and more of the
future we start becoming more and more
future oriented
and that's um really the process of
civilization the process of denying our
needs now in order to think for the
future so instead of spending all of our
day on the beach enjoying ourselves
we take time off from leisure on the
beach and spend some time
making a spear or making a fishing rod
so that our productivity in hunting or
fishing tomorrow is going to be higher
and so that ability to think for the
future
is enhanced by our ability to provide
for the future and we do that with
durable goods but then
money ends up being the best mechanism
for providing for the future because
you the future is uncertain so you know
you can um save your apples and oranges
you can save the spears
you can save the animal that you hunted
but these things
you know first they rot and they're not
very good at holding on to their value
over time but even if they wear
even if you know have objects that are
durable the problem with them is that
you don't know if you need them
tomorrow or next month or next year
you're not sure if you're going to be
needing them and you might end up not
needing them and you might end up not
finding anybody who needs them or
finding somebody who needs them but
doesn't value them much and won't give
you much in exchange
money allows you the optionality of
saving the most liquid good the most
saleable good so it's something that you
can sell tomorrow with the least
uncertainty it has the most liquidity
the most ability to
be sold without a loss in its value so
money is our most advanced technology
and our best technology for moving value
into the future
and so
i think history really i argue this in
all my books is that really history we
see
um we can think of it as a process of
our money gets harder and so our money
is gets better at holding on to its
value for the future
and by harder i mean harder to produce
we we find things that are hard to
produce that are
better at holding on to their values so
they hold on to their value better for
the future and that allows us to plot
and plan for the future that makes the
future less uncertain and that makes us
more future oriented in other words it
lowers our time preference
you